You're so far away.
Ain't got too much pride.
Want you back by my side.
Well baby I want that, too.
Baby I would run, run to you.
I would run to you.
And, I would run to you.
The first time you talked to me.
I knew we were meant to be.
When we finally embraced.
Baby, I can't keep this pace.
I love you, there I said it.
I think I'm gonna need a medic.
You filled the hall with flower petals.
Why does my mouth taste like metal?
Baby, I might die without you.
Baby, I might die.
I would run to you.
I'm not as strong as you.
I... to you.
Love is a speeding comet.
I'm in a pool of my own vomit.
Love is a perfect vision.
This is such a bad decision.
Love makes everything serene.
Give me all your morphine.
Baby, I know we said we'd run across the country to be together,...
...but I thought we were being symbolic.
Why can't we fly and meet somewhere in the middle?
Like Kansas City?
It's the Paris of the Plains.
Baby, I love you so much that I would run to you.
You would run to me?
You would run to me!
Baby, I love you so much that I would run to you.
I would run to you.